mariano mazères qui m'amène à matisse
comme un job c'est bon pour trois
minutes mais après 45 ça devient vite en
voyant nomads à vous est loin de faire
l'unanimité
il ya des gens qui vous aiment beaucoup
d'autres qui vous aiment un peu moins
ouais je pense pas que les gens m'aiment
beaucoup même un peu moins je pense
qu'ils m'adorent ou même je suis très
polarisantes je pense pas que quelqu'un
fait moi elle je sais pas non moi c'est
soit tu m'aimes ceux qui m'aiment pas
sébastien et si je te ramène chez lui au
breuil au puy concours ça se veut tu
tombes enceinte
comment avez-vous fait le choix
d'aborder des thèmes aussi cru la
masturbation la fellation
tout ça dans un spectacle s'intitule
femmes tailleur ouais je les fait parce
que moi même j'avais peur de ces sujets
là quand j'ai commencé à faire de
l'humour je me suis dit je veux pas ça
crie je peux parler de sexe j'ai pas
envie de l'emporter et paul hayes me
suis basé là dessus parce que ce sont
des choses qui me faisait part et je me
suis dit tant qu'elle est sur une scène
puis allez parler sur des choses qui me
rendent à la esee tout ça je vais
m'emmerder tout ce qu'ils m'ont rendu à
l'aise dans l'alignement merde
dès le début mariana major j'ai lu
maurice vulgaire et je suis pas d'accord
avec ça je suis pas vulgaire c'est juste
qu'on me donne pas d'autres options mais
en humour
où est la limite jusqu'où on peut pas la
risée je sais pas je le sais pas je sais
pas c'est quoi la limite encore quand je
la tiendrais je voudrais je ne sais pas
pour l'instant j'ai atteint aucune
limite
je pense pas que j'ai atteint une limite
de allô t'es allé trop loin parce que
j'ai confiance en mon intelligence et
j'ai confiance à l'intelligence des gens
pourtant il ya des gens qui pensent
vraiment vous êtes allé trop loin
parfois comme en faisant quoi aux gens
de se masturber non mais par exemple ça
dingue sur cette femme en surprenant un
avion ça va réagir dans les réseaux
sociaux étaient mal écrite si elle était
bien écrite cela leur était drôle était
pas bien écrite le problème la blague
elle était mal écrite si elle était
bonne cela leur était drôle mais comme l
était pas bonne je les écris rapidement
en état dans un avion je m'en allais en
vacances
l'état d'esprit dans lequel j'étais
était complètement super dur et jamais
dû faire ça mais en même temps le
scandale a duré 20 minutes pour allaiter
les 20 minutes où est ce que je pensais
de l'aéroport jusqu'à ma chambre d'hôtel
que j'ai faite tabarouette aller vite ça
mais en même temps c'est pas grave parce
que ça m'a fait écrire un numéro sur la
grossophobie est ce que les gens qui
réagissent à vos blagues parce que
parfois vous manqué de personnalité
publique
oui je pendant votre premier spectacle
maquis de
vous êtes un peu boursouflé beaucoup
boursoufle époque vous avez un retour
d'appel
maintenant il le sait il était là
pendant mes rodage et venir ma première
il trouvait ça bien drôle
la fan numéro et d'éric lapointe semaine
c'est un peu comme d'autres bonnes je
vis qu'on aurait crise et dans une
sécheuse avec une poignée de cloud moi
je m'attaque pas aux gens qui sont
atteints m'attaque aux gens qu'ils
peuvent en prendre
je vais pas m'attaquer à quelqu'un et
c'est pas une attaque je ne vais pas me
moquer ou taquiner quelqu'un qui ne peut
pas se défendre et qui ne connut des
pires mais je suis sûr qu'ils rappellent
même pas de la blague jury d'ariane
moffatt jeter les jouer au tennis avec
elle n'y a pas longtemps puis elle
trouvait ça bien drôle car les nerfs on
sait que je dis qu'elle a une grosse
voix je vais jamais allée m'attaquer à
quelqu'un qui pourra pas se défendre
mais pourquoi paul fille qui le rend
trident poli je supporte est une tâche
bien entendu dire qui a revu et corrigé
il se moque de moi puis les p o qui se
moque de moi mais qui me mécary le
caricaturiste tant mieux tant mieux
c'est bien correct faut qu'on en prenne
c'est un peu le problème je pense avec
le milieu culturel au québec c'est que
tout est tellement contrôler par les
mêmes personnes au québec bonnes chances
d'aller me régale ok pas censuré je fais
juste leur dire le mot mariana bazo puis
ils disent que je suis un loose cannon
quelqu'un qu'on peut pas contrôler mais
vous êtes débine
vous pensez que j'arrive sur une scène
et je fais n'importe quoi elle te payer
40 pias je suis ce que je fais je suis
pas mongols je sais ce que je fais j'ai
travaillé les choses faut qu'on fasse un
peu plus confiance
le gala des olivier devrait être le gars
le plus écouté parce qu'ils se posaient
de le plus drôle c'est rarement le plus
drôle parce que les textes sont révisés
par des avocats
c'est épouvantable vous mais de couper
l'herbe sous le pied de la fonction
principale de l'humour qui est la
liberté
si on réduit et je pense que ça c'est
quelque chose qui va falloir qu'on
travaille pour quoi vous pensez que je
veux pas que j'ai pas un humain un gars
là encore à ce jour j'aimerais ça mais
je sais qu'on va regarder mes textes je
sais comment me dire tu fais pas dire
christ peut pas et reste ici c'est vrai
quand les gens écoutent crespy estime
marc leprat il attrape tout le cancer
tout à coup ça me fait ça me sort de moi
en fait de me rendre compte à quel point
on se dit tellement ouvert l ouverture
c'est de laisser la créativité lui faire
confiance
faites confiance aux gens j'ai réalisé
que je suis une femme je suis moitié
arabe moitié latine puis j'ai l'air
d'une green fait que je suis vraiment
heureuse de pommes levé ce matin aux
états unis votre prochain spectacle
s'intitule éponyme ouais donc ça va
parler à wadi rum les bras à sa ne dis
pas qu'elle est en fait le chien est
tellement et polie que je vais jamais
faire de d'entrevue par rapport à mon
show - tripoli jusqu'au bout du concept
sérieusement ouais ouais ouais je veux
que ce soit le plus impolie possible oh
ça va être impoli j'espère que ma
première se fasse dans un bar de
schlague c'est mon plus grand rêve
au moins ça va être impoli et polis
impoli le plus impoli mais comment vous
pouvez aller encore plus loin que vous
allez lol on va toujours plus loin
qu'est ce qu'on fait la journée où
est-ce qu'on arrête d'aller plus loin on
est mort on est quand même vous allez
comme votre lourde assez corrosif et
n'ont pas causé si on enlève les sacs de
trois black de cacao goethe aussi juste
aussi propre que marjo lionel mazars
merci beaucoup c'est un véritable pause
et c'est à vous c'était vrai fleurs
bravo c'est un vrai décor on se dit